we begin with tunisia's biggest
political crisis since the 2011
revolution that introduced democracy
president saeed has sacked the
government including the prime minister
hisham
shishi in frozen parliament for 30 days
the military have been deployed to the
government palace and stopped all
workers from entering the building
the biggest political group another
party is calling it
a coup well this is the scene
in the capital tunis demonstrators from
both sides of the political divide
were outside parliament in the past
hours security forces
stormed the offices of al jazeera and
kicked the staff out the building
the military is blocking the speaker of
parliament
from entering the building he remains in
his car
surrounded by supporters sarah hired
begins our coverage with this report
celebrations on the streets of tunisia's
capital tunis in the hours after the
president dismisses the prime minister
and freezes parliament for 30 days
[Music]
it's the first time in my life i've
heard the head of a state make a right
decision
we've taken our country back this is the
first time we're out on the streets to
celebrate
president supporters made their way
through the streets
welcoming news of political change
[Applause]
earlier thousands had protested in
several cities about government failures
and crippling coronavirus rates
[Applause]
crowds shouted slogans against the
ruling and nada party
and prime minister hisham mashishi
calling for the dissolution of
parliament and chanting
down with the regime
we have come down today to resist this
regime they take our money and curse us
they have not done anything to the
people always fighting it is enough
how can nine ministers rule an entire
country we have starved and the people
are lost
police blocked all streets leading to
the city's main thoroughfare using tear
gas to break up the crowds
it was a key site for the tunisian
revolution a decade ago that toppled
long-time president xenal abdin bin
ali and unleashed the arab spring
uprisings
[Applause]
soon after the president called an
emergency meeting saying the measures
were needed to save
the country
the first decision is to freeze all the
powers of the parliament
the constitution does not allow the
parliament to be dissolved
but it does not stand in the way of
freezing all its work
the second decision is to lift the
immunity of all members of parliament
and for those of whom a case is related
to
i will take care over the public
prosecution
but critics including the speaker of
parliament have called the president's
actions a coup
these decisions have no basis in the
constitution nor in the law
and we are against them because in short
it is a coup
against the constitution a coup against
the revolution
and a coup against public and private
liberties in the country
the president made a misinterpretation
that actually clashes with the reality
there has been a rivalry between the
president prime minister and speaker
that's prevented action to tackle
surging unemployment and crumbling state
services tunisia has also been
overwhelmed by the coronavirus pandemic
facing one of africa's worst outbreaks
hospitals are overcrowded and
under-resourced
and on saturday tunisia reported a
record 317 deaths
from the virus
to many the country's deepening economic
and social problems have
undermined support for democracy some
critics say
that very democracy is now in danger
al jazeera security forces dressed in
civilian clothes stormed the offices of
al jazeera in tunis they asked all
journalists to turn off their phones and
then remove the staff from the building
we spoke to al jazeera's tu nispirio
bureau chief lutfihaji about the
situation
the security forces stormed al jazeera
offices in tunis and
asked the staff to leave the office they
prevent the staff from even taking their
personal belongings
and they said
that they represent the security
defense in tunisia
i asked him if he has a judiciary permit
and he said no
we don't have this but these are the
instructions
of the home ministry despite the fact
that we have
laws in tunisia and they cannot do that
our conception this is not fair
this is against fairness because it
doesn't depend
on our judiciary ruling until now we
don't know the fate
of us they have the office they have the
keys
and we will go to the judiciary and
we will see what will happen later
security forces are surrounding
the office and the facility of the
office
and they are upstairs as well
they prevent anyone to enter the office
of al jazeera and they prevent us from
even having our
personal belongings on the computers
they prevent
anyone to take anything from the office
there is
a new decision which is not fair and
this might develop into
other actions because in tunisia during
the last 10 years
we get used to the freedom of press
freedom of work
respect of law let's go to muhammad
valley he's covered tunisia extensively
for us he joins us now
muhammad let's start with the question
of the constitutionality of the
situation
does it give the president the right to
do what he's done
well sami according to um if you look at
the
article 80 of the constitution it allows
the president to take some
emergency measures if the security of
the nation is at
threat is under threat and if there are
the situation is deteriorating for the
country as a whole the the interests of
the nation and the
security of people and so on
however the president cannot take
those measures without consultation with
the government without consultation with
the uh
with the um the other branches of the
government including the parliament
but what we have now right now is
the president has frozen the parliament
he has sacked the government
and there was no consultation prior to
that so this is why the opponents of the
president say that this is
unconstitutional
rashford the speaker of the parliament
described it as a coup
also the body that should be allowed
that
is you know empowered to resolve this
kind of disputes doesn't exist the
constitutional court
has never been formed so these are
aspects of the
of the crisis in tunisia that have been
accumulating over the last few years
and actually over the last decade and we
can say
and now they've reached the head and
most concerning
in this regard is the silence since
yesterday night
of the president himself we have
demonstrations in the streets
we have the military out in the streets
and they are
blocking entry to buildings to
government buildings
we have acts of
silencing the media like what happened
to al jazeera lots of
spots of silence there that are very
concerning to the public
and to the international community as
well what's going on
something is going on behind the scenes
and we don't know about it
and that's very very dangerous mohammed
i'm going to ask you to stay with us
because we've got on the line we're
going to go to ahmedali he joins us on
the line
from tunis ahmed it looks like the
situation is deteriorating since the
last time we spoke what's happening
yeah absolutely i mean
now um there are clashes between the
demonstrators
both sides both groups
we got people wounded and we
can see we can watch we can see blood
and this is a bad sign really
and he the other i mean really shocking
news
it's uh the shutdown of al jazeera you
know
it's a it's a bad sign it's very bad
sign
so i mean we as journalists we had lots
of acquisition
uh since the revolution we were
reporting uh
freely i mean sometimes uh problems
occurred but
not in this way uh we never heard i mean
this
this belonged to ben ali i mean when he
used to
shut down media bureaus
and now i mean we are asking ourselves
we are wondering what will
happen next i mean it's a really bad
sign
um i mean shutting down the al jazeera
bill
maybe you know we don't know what is i
mean
what's the intention behind it so
everybody really is concerned for the uh
for the uh freedom of expression and uh
press liberty ahmed
i just heard you say you were referring
to clashes
and you said we can see blood can you
please explain
what you meant by that okay i
because we we saw i mean blood i mean
people were attacking each other with
stones with a bottle of water
and lots of people got wounded i mean
not killed no casualties so far and this
is the a good thing but you know
is this ahmed are we talking about
clashes between
the different protesters civilians or
we're talking about yeah
okay please so between the civilians the
civilians
the policeman i mean in the early
morning hours
succeeded to disperse them to be in the
middle uh
to calm down the situation but now it
looks like
the situation is out of control and
uh as long as we see this i mean
there are lots of concerns
okay that was ahmadly there explaining
to us the latest
escalating situation on the ground where
apparently we are now hearing about
clashes between
rival protesters that uh
that seem to have heated up well you
might ask what's led to this political
turmoil
let's bring you some background on this
in 2011 tunisia's first free and fair
election saw the
another party win a majority in
parliament with munso murzuki
as president protests started again the
following year and have happened
periodically ever since
people have been unhappy about the high
levels of unemployment
the 2014 parliamentary election didn't
help
fix the economic woes tunisia is still
trying to secure a new loan from the
international monetary fund
attacks on foreign tourists in 2015
hurt the tourism reliant economy even
more
more by 2020 after months of failed
attempts to form a government
a new prime minister elias fakhfaq was
brought in
he was forced out later in the year over
a corruption scandal though
anti-government protesters were back on
the streets again on sunday the
mishandling of the pandemic has
exacerbated the difficult living
conditions for millions who've been
calling
for support from those in power
max kellyanne is a political scientist
specializing
in the middle east and north africa at
the institute of development studies
at the university of sussex he joins us
by skype
from freiburg in germany good to have
you with us so the latest lines talk
about how the speaker of parliament has
been calling on the president
to reverse his decision do you think
the president will be listening to that
i imagine he'll be listening to it i i
doubt he'll be following it
um i don't think that is an unsurprising
call but it is the logical call for the
speaker parliament to make
it is a logical call for parliament to
not accept it's it's freezing but
um there seems to be a larger kind of
plan
in place including obviously the very
very worrying
attack against your colleagues and tunis
that does not make me think that
this will that this will be walked back
too quickly
that being said there are political
forces within tunisia and this includes
the labor unions this includes
wider civil society organizations um and
this includes uh the remaining uh forces
of parliament
that can push back against this and i
think that can still affect
uh how this is going to play out so this
is still very much a developing
situation and i think it'll be important
to keep that in mind in the next couple
of days
how worrying is it now when you look at
the escalation that's happening
that now al jazeera's offices have been
shall we say visited by the authorities
closed down the
journalists kicked out the sort of
posture that we're seeing
being taken on the streets it all it
doesn't bode well
for a sort of shall we say civilian
normal civilian
evolution it
it really doesn't and i think that's why
looking at these developing events is
really really critical
there's one discussion around what the
president announced yesterday and
whether that is legal within the article
80 of the constitution which is not but
that's one discussion
and then i think there's what's
happening today and very very few good
events
start with plainclothes security
officers taking away the phones of
people al jazeera
and so i think looking at that today
looking at the behavior of security
forces today will be really really
critical
especially as we talk about clashes on
the street it's also important to
mention that the tunisian police
has a history of violence against
protesters and violent civilians which
we've seen protests about in the last
couple of days as well
um so i think looking at the at the role
of the security forces here is critical
it's also really difficult and important
to be cautious in how we
interpret these events in the street in
the coming days
there's support for what's happening by
some protesters and i think that that is
in itself important to recognize it is
an indication that the political system
so far has failed tunisians and the
absolutely disastrous
cobit crisis that the country is going
through right now is an indication of
that alongside high unemployment and a
deep economic crisis
but also not everybody's on the street
and not being on the street right now is
not consenting to what's happening
so i think evaluating more deeply how
this sits in public opinion
but also in the opinion of tunisia's key
institutions
is going to be the key thing that
determines how this develops moving
forward
all right thank you very much good to
get your analysis on that
let's go to tunis space journalist rabab
aloi now joins us from there so
now we're looking at a situation where
we're hearing of clashes between
protesters on the street indicative
perhaps
of how deep divisions run within
tunisian society towards what the
president has done
yes so right now the situation is so
critical especially right now while
clashes
are are between protesters
protesters who are supporting uh the
majority leading parties in the
parliament
nada cartoons and al-karama coalition
and on the other side protesters who are
supporting uh
side decisions uh to
follow the government so i think the
situation is
so critical we need to be more vigilant
at the same time
as a journalist i'm afraid i'm confused
when i saw the police officer officers
who stormed the office of al jazeera
channels unfortunately these images
remind me ben ali's regime
when he used to imprison journalists and
when
he used used to prohibit uh
international
uh channels uh so i'm a little bit
confused now i think freedom of
expression
and freedom of press is really
threatened right now
and at the same time some journalists i
joined i joined
them this this morning they told me that
they find
it difficult to took some a picture of
the protesters
so i think we need to be more vigilant
right now
and that segues into what i was going to
ask you just the the clamp down that's
taking place against journalists the
closure of al jazeera's office is that
indicative that the army
is not going to try and remain neutral
in this that it is taking
if not a stance that that could be
described as
very dictatorial but at least the stance
that is
favorable towards the president
until now the army are neutral and
objective and uh when i talked
to some of them they told me we are just
executing
uh what president isaiah said we don't
take
any parts or any political uh parties
but at the same time
i've as i witnessed it this morning i
saw that
they are trying to stay just in the
middle between the the protesters
between
another supporters and kai side
supporters i mean the classes aren't
between the the
army and the protesters the clashes are
between
the both side of the protesters
and what about the role of the national
labor union how critical is that right
now
so they are now handling a
meeting we don't know uh their reaction
but
i think they will uh support kaisei
decisions
they always supported him and when they
called for a national
dialogue last november to solve this uh
political crisis
they they said that they will stay and
support
president thai side against another
party
and the majority leading parties in in
the parliament
i think probably they will take also uh
the the kaisai side but at the same time
i i'm
surprised because some political parties
who supported
president kaisai during the elections in
2019
now they are against them like the
democratic current who
now speak to who spoke to
um to express their disappointment uh
to see this decision to see the uh the
uh chapter 18 from the constitution
elected
right now they they described their
reaction as uh
shocked and uh confused so
i think there is uh also division in the
opposition but
for the labor uh labor uh
that now they are in a meeting so we
don't know yet but probably they will
take uh take position with president
kaisei
all right thank you very much for giving
us your
observations of what's happening there
thank you a short while ago security
forces dressed in civilian clothes
stormed the officers of al jazeera in
tunis
they asked all journalists to turn off
their phones they removed everyone from
the building
and we spoke to al jazeera's tunis
bureau chief at the time ludwig
about the situation
the security forces stormed al jazeera
offices in tunis and
asked the staff to leave the office
they prevent the staff from even taking
their personal belongings
and they said
that they represent the security
defense in tunisia
i asked him if he has a judiciary permit
and he said no
we don't have this but these are the
instructions
of the home ministry despite the fact
that we have
laws in tunisia and they cannot do that
our conception this is not fair
this is against fairness because it
doesn't depend
on our judiciary ruling until now we
don't know the faith
of us they have the office they have the
keys
and we will go to the judiciary and
we will see what will happen later
security forces are surrounding
the office and the facility of the
office
and they are upstairs as well
they prevent anyone to enter the office
of al jazeera and they prevent us from
even having our
personal belongings on the computers
they prevent
anyone to take anything from the office
there is a new decision which is not
fair
and this might develop into other
actions
because in tunisia during the last 10
years
uh get used to the freedom of press
freedom of work
respect of love
pauline ades novell is spokesperson for
reporters without borders
she says they're staying vigilant of any
attacks
on media outlets in tunisia
you could see the signs of the coup
a lot in the last few days when they
showed some
doctors or directors of hospitals crying
because of lack of
oxygen hospitals and other you know
theatrical acts to pave the way for the
decision of
the president there are no grounds no
reasons for the president
to resort to such draconian measures if
it's the corona the corona is an
international
it's an international phenomenon which
all countries
big and small couldn't really control if
it is a matter of
tourism yes corona the corona and lack
of
tourist athletic tunisian economy so the
president chooses
like many dictators like the fascists
during the second
before the second world war they play on
the emotions of the people
and on the misery of the people and they
always find a party to
you know to to blame and in this
instance
the president wants to share that the
presidential system
is the best because he always declared
that he wanted the
presidential uh system claiming that
because he is voted by
high percentage therefore he should have
supremacy over parliament
as a professor himself of constitutional
law
no this is not the case at all
is editor-in-chief of michigan a
tunisian news
analysis website he says it's a big
question of debate among tunisians as to
whether the president's move
is constitutional we've seen
already uh both critics and supporters
taking to the media in
the last several hours uh some who are
saying that it's
anti-constitutional perhaps an
overzealous interpretation of article
80.
people are reading the article over and
over again to see exactly what powers
the president
does have at this moment we saw a video
shared
uh by another social media it had uh uh
russia nushi trying to get into
parliament uh very late last night about
three in the morning and they were
confronted by uh
military members of the military who
were there uh blocking the entrance
um there uh there was an argument
between them the military said that they
were following orders that they could
not open the doors to them
that they had closed off parliament to
them in accordance with the president's
decision to freeze parliament the
president said he doesn't have the power
to dissolve
parliament but he did have the power to
freeze parliament's
activities for one month there's also a
question whether it will be temporary
um and what will happen in this one
month period but certainly anatha and
its supporters
um who have quite a lot to lose are uh
uh against that there have been uh
attacks on enough the
headquarters police forces actually uh
defended the headquarters from people
who
uh had gone there to to attack the
headquarters they had used tear gas we
saw
a video that our reporter uh uh had
shared very late at night
uh showing that security forces were
trying to protect the nha headquarters
uh so there is a role of the security
forces to try and play
uh as much of a neutral role as possible
let's go to muhammad val who's covered
tunisia extensively for us muhammad
let's break this down and
ask some basics here first of all is
who does the president represent is this
one of those situations in which you can
say
this is an attempt by the old guard to
try and take back
power well sami uh
tunisian president has always claimed
that he represents the people of tunisia
and probably this is the this is what he
relies on in what he did yesterday he
relied on this particular
um aspect of the constitution because
the first
probably one of the first articles of
the constitution was that
the the source of sovereignty
in the constitution is the people of
tunisia so he's
using that to say that what he does is
for the interest of the of the people of
tunisia and that his support came from
the people of tunisia
they elected him from no particular
political party
and he is relying on this to interpret
every action he takes
constitutionally but his opponents are
saying that
yes that's the broad picture of things
but there are details
and he did not stick to those details
including for instance the fact that he
should
he should coordinate with
the other branches of power before
taking a decision like the one he took
yesterday night
article 80 stipulates that you should
consult with the government
and consult with the parliament before
he takes the decision
within the realm of emergency like
within the
that scope of emergency measures that
the president is allowed to take
constitutionally to
to help prevent a problem or a situation
that could affect the interest of the
nation or the security of the nation all
right let's talk about another
contextual
uh question here unemployment increased
this year muhammad to almost 20
poverty remains high at around 15
gdp fell in the first quarter of this
year
the background to this successive
governments failing to revive the
economy
that's absolutely the case that's where
ice syed takes his powers and his you
know his
what he considers the legitimacy of what
he does
he says that the fact that these
governments
failed to serve the tunisian people is
enough
reason for him to depose them uh
he considers that the the number one
criterion
for any government a government is uh
is appointed in order to serve the
people in order to solve the problem of
unemployment in order to
prevent a health crisis like the one
that tunisia is
is uh is living now and
he for him they failed miserably in that
respect and that's enough
enough reason for him to depose them and
to he has
announced that he's going to appoint a
new government in the next few hours
but we are waiting for him to do that
the people of tunisia are waiting for
him
and they don't know where is he going to
bring these government members from from
which party from which base
so he's leaving the country waiting for
uh for any developments in the next few
hours
and if no announcement is made that is
going to be
a source of grave concern if the
president doesn't show up
and if he doesn't tweet or send a
message to the people
in the next few hours it's gonna it's
gonna probably cause
an escalation on the streets because we
have seen these confrontations we have
seen
people wounded and the military is still
standing by but not
ex not absolutely because they have
blocked government buildings
and security forces are doing actions of
the type we have seen against the
al-jazeera bureau
so things are little by little getting
out of control if
no voice from the president if no sound
if no
message comes from the president himself
and one imagines appointing a new
government a new prime minister
without a process without elections
without even the parliament
being that's not going to help the
divisions go away one imagines
exactly that's what i have just said he
said he's going to
keep the situation like this for a month
and during that month he's going to
accumulate all the powers
all the different powers of the
government the three branches in his own
hands
is he going to be able to do this we
have to look at the factors of power
the basis on which he could do this he
should have the army on his side
he should have the labor unions on his
side he should have a huge majority of
people protesting in the streets on his
side
and these are the factors that we should
observe
during the next few hours and next few
days if he has those
factors probably he will be able to to
push his
his reforms or his decisions all right
thanks so much mohammed val